we probably went through a long a period
of time as Homo sapiens without law then
with law law probably is a development
of four or five thousand years maybe
earlier we only have written records
that go back to Hammurabi lipid Ishtar
the earliest versions of the Bible law
is a very important way of controlling
rage passion revenge jealousy and law
must reflect all of these emotions as
well the law historically developed some
experience I wrote a book called the
genesis of justice which dealt with the
origins biblical law and the point I
made is the book of Genesis doesn't have
law there's no law in Genesis the love
begins in Exodus Mount Sinai the rules
of law and Genesis shows us how a world
operates without law and it's a terrible
world in which people do awful things to
each other and the God character in the
book of Genesis has to destroy the whole
world by the flood and then has to try
to recreate it from a scratch and we see
human beings operating on the basis of
instinct some good some bad the
dysfunctional families of the of the
Bible killing their enemies sometimes
even preemptively and and then we move
toward the development of some kind of a
common law some understanding to at the
end of the book of Genesis what's right
and what's wrong and then eventually to
codification in the book of Exodus with
the Ten Commandments and then the rules
that follow in the Ten Commandments so
low is essential to civilized society
every tyrant understands that what
tyrants want our laws that they can
impose on others but are not restrictive
of themselves and we in Western culture
say no one's above the law and everybody
must be subject to the rule of law it's
also part of democratic accountability
the law has to be published invisible
accessible to all and subject to
challenge and change and that's what the
rule of law
is and probably there's no more
important contribution to civilization
and progress